[Music]  seems like it should be easy to detect a  whole new particle after all there's  only 17 fundamental elementary particles  and objects like protons and neutrons  aren't fundamental at all they can decay  let me explain when physicists first  observed the phenomenon known as beta  decay the process by which the atomic  number of an element can change without  its atomic mass number changing this can  happen in a couple of different ways in  all these interactions no matter which  one beta decay will one way or another  change the element which we're dealing  with it'll change the atomic number  there's loads of different laws that  describe an incredible detail how these  kinds of particles interact transform  carry charge and what their masses are  thus began a decades-long search to find  neutrinos directly and examine their  properties